woods mark my entire security system
just went offline great give me a second
while we wait for Baja I'll be right
back okay goodbye
I'm back you want to hear something
weird
always yeah somehow the three ethernet
cables plugged into specifically the
Wi-Fi router we're all unplugged you're
[ __ ] dead
did you record it all right you ready to
play I'm for that one cinematic what the
hell unknown creature
men Bigfoot's really violent in this
game yeah you're not happy Oh Washington
okay the Pacific Northwest where Bigfoot
lives better than it did before
yeah no it's just improved I gotta admit
okay I don't remember any of the
controls from before Oh me neither
oh hey who wants the drone uh I've flown
the drone before but it's not that
complicated so so I've never flown the
drone all you don't apply yeah okay
there's three rights that's good start
there's three flare guns that's also a
good start tracking bullets tens what
the hell is the tenth four I don't know
what raw meat we got meat we hit the
side what our [ __ ] yeah what is deuce
oh yeah we did tracking bullets okay I'm
getting meat hang on Oh Oh God you're so
gross how you bring up your menu of
stuff it was a whole circle [ __ ] you I
said that was a really low key wolf
attack I'm not taking tracking bullets
so who wants to be our tracker there's
enough tracking boats for everybody
there just Runa but yeah I'm not taking
any tracking bullet I've already got
okay what you're just refused what did
you find
listen listen to my listen oh I thought
here if one of us is the tracker uh-huh
we stick together
aha two of us can be ready to shoot at
any given time while one puts that
tracker in there you're right okay that
makes sense I'll do it since I already
picked up dragon balls all right I'm
gonna pick up the drone then I'm not
just being refusal for being a bud I'm
really in like you know you could see
how I would think that no I can I get it
but like there was there was a madness
to my method right in the dark not
liking that no you know pulls up your
tablet and the the to do list is catch
Bigfoot if I've lost people I'll stick
with this I'm good you guys get
everything else there's more flares over
here I don't
no bullets my five bullets total okay
okay well you guys remember the rules of
how this works right the rules no flare
scares them away we draw right traps put
meat and bury the trap
okay guys where are we headed which way
we go and where's Bigfoot sniff em out
all right scares them off we set traps
we use the meat that's that's the thing
right
yeah and there was meat in the fridge
you guys grab the meat in the fridge
there's snacks on the ground I didn't
have any meat sticks and rocks we build
a fire our temperature gauge in the
bottom right does matter I've got my
rifle with tracking bullets out and
ready to go okay man they really
improved this this is a lot better yeah
this is way more complicated than the
last time I played it
I'm alone wait oh no I'm back at the
camp
what the camp what I don't know what I
do didn't follow us we went through the
Western trail we're following the road
whoa what was that
oh dear dear let me shoot it yeah it's
too late it ran away and there's a guy
in the room oh wow
wait cuz you shined your flashlight on
my scope I couldn't see there was a
flare on it oh that's weird
yeah I literally couldn't see it I can
turn the flashlight off but then it's
just well I mean that's good left it I
just not pointed at my scope well I
didn't try to us trying to look at the
deer and then it's just the timing was
unfortunate yeah well now we know don't
we oh okay are you blind
it's so fun yeah it's good having
friends is fun all right let's move out
guys as the de facto leader of this
expedition I say we go this way I'm
hearing a lot of noises I'm hearing some
yes and critters whoa what is that I
don't know what is that that's that
ain't good that's not one of the law
people oh it's kind of like Satan's goal
I think Bigfoot's governor's than around
here well it was a body around here
did you hear that do you hear that like
I just know I know there was a there was
a wood crack like there you know if your
dad no I'm gonna get my gun out though I
heard like wood cracking Lee
sticks being stepped on oh I heard that
was that yes he had a feeling there's a
body or a person around here somewhere
there was a snow modem what do you mean
there was a body there was a freakin
skull modem we're looking for for lost
people remember alright okay alright
well alright is this the same small
modem do can we break this with a knife
the totem baby wait wait you're far away
from us just so you know god this rain
is really coming down
I swear to God in the distance I'm
hearing like moaning or something I know
I hear it but I can't hear it through
the goddamn brain I feel like that's
probably on purpose
oh that was a noise what was that it was
a deer it's fine it's deer okay that
scared the piss out of me you do what
you do you hear that you want to check
it out yes god that's scared thing that
legitimately scared the piss out of me I
have piss everywhere I didn't even come
out of the right hole it just shot out
everywhere I know right my pores what
pores of pits yeah piss pores they call
it god I can't hear anything
rain oh weren't the wall what the hell
why is it green remark everyone knows
this oh right you're right you're right
I'm stupid I didn't go to late class the
land is not supposed to have green oh my
God look at the lighting in the fog I
see yeah they really enhance the
graphics but I don't know if that's a
good thing it's spookier now why is it
sabrine what the [ __ ] I think it's
supposed to be like this swamp bug
Rosetta oh hell yeah those uh Northeast
was over toward Bob's direction from
yeah that was I think it's fine so long
as it doesn't charge us I mean I killed
the last one with my knife
so the wolves aren't a huge thing I mean
technically I also shot it so oh okay
well then - nice wings it's not a
raccoon it's good you killed it it's
dead it's where is it I don't see a spot
I just see a getting meat oh it fell
wait aunt got here's the meat oh if that
Rogers man that wolf
out of nowhere that wolf was huge I
didn't see the wolf care of it you must
have closed your eyes and pure tear or a
building do in the middle of the labor
you see south east east south east run
it across the swamp okay well I see him
I see him in the middle I lost him or
you can't see him anymore I took a shot
at a deer I don't know if I hit it great
job wait
thanks death whoa what the oh oh that's
an angry that's an angry scream I got my
flare gun out okay let me get one
tracker on it if it comes this way I
don't see it anymore always way the [ __ ]
far away in south southeast now no south
southwest even southwest he's like super
far he's like across the water alright
let's check out this building then okay
I don't know what we saw guys it may not
have been Bigfoot it might have been
just a tall man Swamp house sure is the
first aid kit Bob get any bullets if
there are bullets in here yeah I've only
got the five rounds yet this box looks
empty
take more of these flares then Bob what
does the signal flare do is that just
light it scares them away okay do you
want to go towards Bigfoot try to tag
him
sure yeah he went off almost straight
south of us hey the sun's coming up
that's cool I hear oh okay that sounds
like a big wolf the rains gone thank
goodness I'm gonna go around right here
wha what what was that what was odd you
hear that wait no I did not hear that
what no what it was like a blob League
ugly sound from the swamp like a like a
swamp monster sound what are you talking
about I didn't hear anything I really
just like I from like right nice to me
legitimately didn't hear anything my dad
heard it they heard it I'm not crazy
you're crazy I'm not I don't think
you're crazy you're crazy
the spirit seems very familiar doesn't
have a cave up here there didn't he have
one he had like a cave but this is a
different map yeah it's slightly
different but also the lake is good well
actually no that used to be a lake now
it's a swamp so it is slightly different
Oh ahead of us it's Wade you sure is or
is that mark no that's Wade
wayde's red left I'm going up through
this pass to see what's up here
okay that's where we're headed wait no
we've got a different path okay that's
towards the middle Bob let's Circle up
and keep going around are you with me
we're the I'm right behind him right
behind you we don't have stamina right
we can just like run all the time
I think you kinda do if you run forever
you whoa oh my god Kangnam
oh my god shoot him with a flare you
missed yeah okay wait you okay yeah all
right
only got one swing Hills back up yeah so
Bob you gotta here I actually hit him i
right now we see where is that oh cool
Wow we do okay snap all right all right
want to follow him um I mean I guess if
he starts to charge us we should set up
a trap so he runs over it agreed
wait guys there's a cave up here at the
end at the where I am
I look like an adult I mean the unknown
cave right now all right coming how long
does that track her last should we save
this for later no no it's fine running
away so you'd if we tracked and it might
wear off before we got to him yeah I
have a I have a leg here not good yeah
that's good man or maybe an arm one of
the water peoples oh there's a there's a
head with a spine on this is great a
night-vision battery first-aid kit here
well Wade why don't you grab that first
date I guess it's still tracking him
he's just kind of like probably popping
a squat down by that road down there
anyone else here rumbling yells oh I'm
here in rumbly else there's a lantern
right there just larks
oh yeah that turned on why'd that turn
on whoa you can turn whoa yeah weird
music yeah what yeah what is this oh
it's coming back oh he's coming back
he's coming no he stopped oh no he's
coming he's coming back his cave should
we trap this yeah yeah maybe we should
trap this cave quick oh he's coming
quick guys who he's got a quick and
I put a mean mcwrap and then cover it
with the he's right around the corner
and then I mask
all right all right it's ready to go
everyone hide I guess no I don't know in
the cave I don't know I don't like that
that's not a good idea but I doing it's
fine he's coming he's I've got the flare
gun out if you guys have the other guns
I'm stuck in you guys dunk I've got a
I've got a flare well mark you [ __ ]
how in the world did he go around that I
think he was wise to us he's doing it
out he's still hanging out right down
there should I reach wrap this I'll try
Oh sort of on the path that he took
maybe lucky if he charges us just lay
the trap down in front of his path of
his movement you know what I mean he's
heading to swamp house there's not was
there like a hot key for trap I have to
I have to use the wheel and get it out I
think so
let me look hurry up she's coming back
he's coming back he's coming back back
back back back back he's by you go
Knights it's fine hang on I'm dropping a
trap I'm gonna bait him he's gonna come
right to me there is I marry you
where are you are you okay yeah I'm I
trapped in lay if you're sweating
bullets between the tracking right yeah
we haven't done much damage what we
could do is we could Bob you could wound
from up here and look for like buildings
oh yeah that's true yeah this is like a
perfect drone spot yeah I can thrown
from up here this tracker wore off yeah
no no it's still it's just fading I
think so how does this drone work you
never used it I don't know I don't
remember but I think it was pretty
simple
oh yeah there we go and then I do this
aha there we go
there she goes alright so how do I tag
things I don't think you can tag things
I think you just got to remember we're
on the map it roughly is I think if you
get close building it should hopefully
just reveal it so with the drone I don't
know if it will but it's worth trying
wait wait oh my god the drone almost
just crashed itself into the ground why
was that oh it has a certain range - it
can only go so far
no it just like stopped flying and then
I pushed a button and it kept flying
that was wild well thank God you can't
crash it oh wait wait did you hear that
yeah I'm gonna place a trap right here
just to have something know just be
aware when you put meat down he is a
track to do it so maybe not do that how
did you put the meat down I just know I
know I get you said he was attracted to
it but I have zero meat I had to meet
now I've got zero and one didn't go on
the trap I don't know where it went
maybe you can double meet it or
something why do you guys want to meet
it then he's got to get over here we're
discussing control schemes mark alright
okay okay okay but I was looking at
Wayne he was like how to meet in his and
he's like I just said we're don't do it
he's pressed e and one didn't show up so
I thought I was like well I'll try again
just to see cuz I thought the controls
were we I knew I could pick it right
back up fair enough fair enough not seen
any buildings though I got nothing that
shadow effect for me being behind me is
really disconcerting I now see what your
problem was with that yeah it's spooky
where you guys going oh you're going the
other way I'll meet up with you guys the
the roads meet up huh guys I'm hearing
noises
I swear I'm hearing a second set of
footprints near me guys it's probably
fine okay I'm hearing rustling and
bushes
nah it's probably fine okay all right
trust you okay I see a fence over here
there you guys are
another effigy here did we try anything
with those with the knife and everything
knife in it I tried knifing it didn't
seem to do anything and it really kicks
up a lot of dust old dusty bones and all
okay should we be spiking some cameras
around what's that noise yeah what is it
um that's probably good thing right whoa
why there's one of us near one of the
people maybe I don't know can kind of
fan out okay that's - hell yeah that's
just a wolf they're fine God dear god
damn it dawn someone I didn't got a deer
you got it you didn't say you were
shooting a deer I don't really have time
to walk you through the whole process
that was not that was a Bigfoot
you guys hear the Bigfoot what where
where what it was like east of us here
the distance he was all it was hear that
no aha hi hi that's me
I've got a huge feed this another dig at
me like a no no when you call me tiny
foot no I wasn't even talking to you I
know if I thought it was like one of
those side digs of my tiny feet this has
nothing to do with you now might be six
foot four but it I wear a size three
shoe it's not my fault it's kind of your
fault oh this will be average foot man
you know yeah well you're freaked oh
there's a lookout look look at the
lookout
oh there is there's probably bullets in
there there are two traps in here anyone
wanna trap good I've got two traps right
now I've got two traps I've got yes I'll
take it now I have three traps hold the
cameras the camera also has a branch
icon so we can hide the cameras when we
place them okay well depending on how
spicy you guys are feeling we could lay
down some traps and try to get him over
here yeah just let me know how you guys
are putting the meat on the trip so I
don't wanna despawn anymore Bob take
care of it to set this up what I say you
use the lookout or something no what do
you what do you think captain we could
do that what we should do is when we lay
down and he gets trapped in it the other
two should rush up and place traps in a
triangle around him so that he can't
escape we really whale on him yeah we
could knife him close up all we're
talking about that's what I'm talking
about that's what I'm alright well so
we'll do one money trap will he be
attracted to it like basically no matter
what I do in an area where where he has
less places to run I don't know
because I'd like to do it up against
like the fence I feel like that might be
cool
go for it we just got to be far enough
away that he doesn't notice us when he
comes we should be Liam or this should
we get a camera
we're in mask issue that I think you got
a hurry though he might be you might be
close I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna get away
I don't have the camera so I got a
camera okay okay just in case that would
turn off your light tree we got here
we're doing it we're hunting a Bigfoot
on that big boat cute I'll go into the
camera I'll look I think I can do that
from here on your tablet on your tablet
that's it that's stupid you get your
tablet out and then you look at the feet
I'm already looking at it I'm looking at
it more control wait Bob oh God
oh good god Bob is that not what you
wanted not particularly well I ain't
seen nothing about I ain't seeing
nothing that neither you know I could
place a camera too and aiming at us and
that way we can all look at the cameras
and make sure that we could be in the
cameras and watch place another trap
okay putting this second camera down
okay
all right we got a camera too now yeah
camera three down just so like we can
get another angle of ourselves all right
where's the trap one is are there we go
wait no left left can you not see our
names
okay good great did I get the tracker on
him I don't know if I did yes yes he's
okay good all right well that didn't
work
no I don't see our names popping up mark
I do yeah I don't know why you don't
you've got realism mode or something
engaged I'm gonna charge him and I'm
gonna I'm gonna have a trap out and I'm
I'm gonna show you the pro moves that
I've got cuz he's gonna charge right at
me from a distance with my gun out here
we go
hey nerd stupid footed nerd ah he's
really far away yeah he's going I don't
think he's coming back
yeah you better run all right well that
almost worked how how did he sneak up on
us is my question here orde right next
to me and then was just on you to see
that's not fair I think you betrayed us
or something or you made a deal with him
or something no no no no what deal with
the devil no no no I didn't come to you
it's coming to you wait is coming to you
wait wait I'm not here I'm not near you
where why did you wait you're not
talking to me wait what wait listen he
and I are working it out just give us a
minute what what he's company buddy
yeah oh I see him he's running he's
running to Bob he's riding her straight
to Bob he's going straight for bob i
trapped it come at me bro come at me bro
come at me bro come at me bro how did
you miss the trap that seems cheating
I'm gonna get about dying I'm dying
there I ran out of steam and I ran out
damn it right here
but wait what did you do you said you're
not that way
yeah what do you think I did um he
literally ran right around my traveling
blinding flash of light as he ran at me
no no all right good just want to make
sure what my flare icon did absolutely
nothing when I shot it it just made a
dink noise then they turned around and
left well I did shoot a flare yeah oh I
saw you shoot the flare yeah why did you
do it
I've been like that I didn't see it cuz
mine did absolutely nothing my flare
shot did absolutely nothing for me it
looked like it might gun just like
jammed and he left anyway well that was
pretty underwhelmed thanks guys thanks
that was pretty garbage guys yeah I'm
very good at this I think we're bad at
this
[Music]